there was an idea to bring together a
group of remarkable people so when we
needed them they fight the battles that
we never could it's called the Avengers
initiative we're doing here is
completely unprecedented Marvel is
taking all of the characters that
they're putting into their movies and
bringing them all together in a team
franchise movie experience which has
never been done before war s time and we
are hopelessly outgunned
to his self talking about a more complex
piece of machinery here trying to
interface these characters to where they
all make sense all have arcs and nobody
has to do too much heavy lifting though
everybody gets their day in the Sun big
manors soon armored take that away what
are you genius billionaire playboy
philanthropist take all these characters
and you trying to make a unbelievable
situation reality what are you prepared
to do we have hearths mightiest heroes
and they are all these extraordinary
actors playing these extraordinary
characters when do you ever get to see
the scope of the actors on together
first time you see everybody together
BAM they're the Avengers adventure
should be our finest hour
guys I'm bringing the party to you
you